in this morning's ion money we're taking
a closer look at the changing job market
even with unemployment at a 50-year low
43 percent of full-time employees say
they have a job outside of their primary
work that's according to a bank rate
survey in June taking on an extra job
for money or experience is called having
a side hustle Chris Chris Gillan Bao is
the author of 100 side hustles and we
went to one of his networking events to
hear why people want to learn the art of
the side hustle I think side hustles are
changing the landscape in so many ways
these days everybody has always been
doing lots of little projects on their
own but now it's so much more mainstream
I know that I can wake up when I want
and do the things that I like to do and
that I have empowerment and choice and
doing what I love it's about just what
skill do I have that other people could
find valuable it's something that I love
doing and kind of the big secret is we
do it for free the opportunity to share
my work with other people who enjoy it
and make money for that is attractive to
me people have a job they're happy there
but they're like now that I have a
second source of income I feel different
about myself
good morning they all seem to be having
a great a great time 15 million
Americans apparently supplementing their
full-time jobs with side hustles why I
think this is really a shadow of the
financial crisis and and think about
this during the financial crisis a lot
of young people had to go outside of
their work if they were lucky enough to
have a job to get some extra income they
piece together work but it has grown
from the Millennials who really started
this it is now expanded Gen X people you
saw all different people of Ages in that
piece we have baby boomers who say even
after they've retired they want to have
some control an extra stream of income
and in fact Chris Gila both said to me
the reason why people are doing this
it's because it makes them happier it
makes them happier in their lives
and they're better at their real day
jobs but like a third of people say that
they're doing this to supplement their
living expenses they have to they have
to right so so what does that say about
the job market I think there's a little
bit of a
difference here between people who are
forced to go and find something for a
side hustle or a gig maybe they're
driving an uber or a lift maybe they're
delivering but these people decide
hustle folks they're kind of a subset
it's little bit different I will say
about those gig workers we look at this
unemployment rate being at 50-year
lowest which is great on the other hand
we also have to look at wages which are
kind of frozen from where they were 20
years ago for median households on
separate bank rate survey found that
people are really struggling to pay
those bills and that gig work is filling
in the gap the side hustle however it's
sort of like this magical benefit where
it's great if ik does translate into
dollars but you heard these people say
I'm doing something I love it's my
passion and it's up and down the income
stream which is also fascinating I think
that people don't like their real jobs
maybe you really love that job because
it gives you security you have benefits
it's a steady paycheck but there's other
thing you can channel creativity and I
think that's a beautiful comment I was
coming up a side hustle was something
illegal clearly this thing out with the
wrong crowd thank you thank you very
much